[Music]
hello happy Monday look at how fast
Kelly got from one room to the other
room from one stream to another you just
got off daily write daily we talked
about all sorts of stuff and now I'm
here sweet I got you into this stream
because we were able to get the like
Australian version of Detroit become
humans demo I guess it's out earlier for
them than it is for the US I think it
comes out tomorrow for the US anyways
Edie hooked me up and you actually just
went was it LA I was in LA playing
Detroit I played for it was the first
section and depending on how you play
it's like two to two and a half hours
okay so um I think I played for like two
and a half hours I took my time gotcha
and this demo is gonna be a lot shorter
than that uh it's it's like one scenario
one hostage scenario and this is the
sequence that they played live on stage
at PSX if you remember so you probably
have seen this if you're if you're in
the know about Detroit but we're gonna
play through it and see what we can all
right discover I try to save the hostage
hopefully and then we'll see well we'll
try our options there's a lot of options
that you can pick so yeah what do I do
um let's just start let's just do it I
guess um alright I think you know one of
the things people talked about what this
game is like this was kind of weird out
of context and I do think with this
character with Connor he's like a really
like matter-of-fact kinda dude yeah it
does make more sense in context it I
think he's Harvey Dent he's two-faced
he likes coin I do really nice I know it
does look really nice I do like that the
androids aren't like you can't you can
tell them apart from humans really
easily because of those like blue
armbands like they have markers on them
and on their clothes got it but so it's
not like a story about like oh I can't
tell if it's not a Turing test thing
like I can tell oh okay hold on I'm not
I'm not too concerned I'm just kidding
wait a second what her
sorry I've seen this your freak and one
of the obviously big big themes in this
game is androids aren't real people yeah
well okay here if your daughter or you
know was or your family member was being
taken hostage with you on a Android
negotiator I mean he has a little thing
that like tells him the probability of
you'll see it yeah yeah like I don't
know if I trust the Android I guess it
depends yeah I tried you I tried doing
that too so yeah one of the things is
like you can't freely explore because
you do have to follow instructions
because you're an Android so I have to
talk to captain Allen who's over here I
think there's like there's even Batman
type vision essentially which I'll see
you later yeah
it's firing and everything that moves it
already shot down two fine men we can
easily get it what would you like now do
you know it's very robotic okay
okay I'm gonna do emotional shock
apparently he doesn't trust androids
either most people don't as I discovered
in my in my playthrough all right so I'm
gonna understand what happened because I
do think so one of the things that's
talking to Oscar Deus about in the UK he
also checked out the game nice and he
was talking about how this game is
actually like a really cool detective
game when you play as Connor and I love
detective games and I I think there
actually are some really cool things
that you can do because he's an Android
you can lick analyze scenes in real time
okay so that's the weapon in question
that's how you tell what kind of weapon
it was and I'm assuming we can oh yeah
yeah and I I did play through this demo
earlier today so I have at least a
general understanding of what's going on
and as mentioned though of course
there's multiple scenarios because of
different options that can happen and
also different you know different
differing amounts of research that you
do that then as you had said earlier
there is kind of like he has this
probability meter that he has like Oh am
I gonna succeed or fail and you know the
more evidence or the more information
you gather kind of increases your
likelihood of succeeding so as you saw
right there it was like really brief we
might have covered it with my hot pip
which I guess with us for a second cuz
everywhere yeah I think I can bring it
back but basically you can reconstruct
crime scenes Bob Jones and the twitch
shows asking if this is a demo not the
first mission it actually is the first
mission was it as far as I know cuz it
was the first thing I played and it was
presented as the first okay that makes
sense so this is kind of just like an
introduction to what deviant androids
are the concept of like oh they're their
hardware
yeah I'm gonna go to the girls room and
see what I can discover in there that's
good that I didn't do that the first to
see I did I didn't do the thing with the
gun case though so I've already learned
more than I did the first time I do this
weird quarter circle back so on that
note from what I I don't know if she's I
got worried about this part it's not
it's okay really loud music she didn't
hear the gunshot it's like face off yeah
but there was casual versus experienced
as options you could pick and I guess
been Janka had walk up walk up and watch
me play and he was like oh you got to
know that these are prompts you got to
do like quarter circle for the quarter
circle backers and like that it wasn't
immediate for me so the deviance name is
Daniel I didn't know this yeah so I
should have came in here the idea the
idea is to just gain as much information
so you can talk like negotiate with him
I guess okay I've unlocked a dialogue or
action which is often beneficial if you
don't know and 59% success right now
which is way higher than than mine and
the other thing is like when you scan
your environment you can see your
current overlay as an Android which I
think is I actually really liked I like
this overlay it helped me kind of
visualize what I was doing also prompts
you to go to different rooms and it
shows the different pathways you haven't
unlocked yet so to understand what
happened there's one more thing I have
to look at okay I think I know what it
is because I already it's not in here
it's over here somebody Daquan I think
asked is it out of the u.s. yet no I
think it's out tomorrow it happens to be
out in Australia first because of like
timing
thank you sealer gaming for telling the
chat as well Brian Deckard says hype
alright we got a bullet wound and I
didn't like fully do it left kidney
perforated let's see that's the dad he
did yeah I was like oh no he's dead I
know I heard you in the office
it's like why uh we got more bullet
wounds he was shot multiple times
actually this will show us this yeah
this one this this little scenario will
kind of show you what's kind of going on
so we're gonna reconstruct and this is
like Connors coolest ability is he can
reconstruct
rewind rewind and then as you're
reconstructing the scene you can stop it
and analyze specific details like this
one okay so it's like oh the father was
holding something what was he holding
we've only analyzed two or one of the
two clues I put us in the bottom right
we'll be okay so I'm going to work on
that while you work on the PIP yeah work
on the PIP
okay we not break anything here father
was holding something there's an event I
can't find I'm gonna find it yeah I've
done this before
you gotta look around I think it's like
is there today it was like in the spot
wherever he you know as he was like ah
okay so we found we found where this
thing fell so we're gonna look at it
what's on it it's pretty important I
know what it is
also yeah if you don't like hold down
the if you don't follow the prompt it'll
like yeah the camera kind of like locks
and then unlocks or something right a
little bit yeah there's some the
controls are a little hard to get used
to but it does make sense after a little
while yeah so you see that the dad was
purchasing a new Android and the whole
thing is like oh that's what caused the
Android - yeah he's freaking out like
I'm getting replaced yeah oh Jesus oh I
don't remember that at all I think I
took too long oh no no no you still got
a look at the kitchen
oh dude oh the other thing I want to
bring up while we're analyzing the
victims is when I at the event they
talked about the different camera work
for each character there's three
different androids that you switch
between oh okay and one of the things
was like Connors is really like straight
forward a standard camera like for you
know any sort of like game like third
person game whereas the other characters
have like more dynamic cameras to give
them a little bit more like a different
feel and I did notice that when I was
playing oh whoops I forgot to
reconstruct this guy okay let's see what
we got here he I feel like if he's a cop
he there's other cops who could have
told me what happened but that's okay
the kaga taught him oh we got that got
that blood on the yeah okay I got a I
got a rewind and
okay there's 300 yeah good yes all right
where's the other I didn't do this once
what's really these are hard yeah I mean
we located the the murder weapon and
there's one where a there's one more
thing that oh it is nice the Hat oh no
hostage hot oh that's awful I didn't
actually see this when I was playing
yeah I didn't reconstruct that one
I totally saw the shoe though the shoe
is a clue that's really awful the child
saw that okay okay I got to do this
weird half-circle yep that's that's the
Hadouken is this a PS exclusive right
yeah okay I'm gonna take the gun I'll
shoot boy this game comes out I think is
it May 25th
it's the twenty-something it's the 25th
25th all right nailed it
I've unlocked another dialogue or action
we got these cool they have these like
tablet magazines that I actually can I
read this right now not yet Oh guys
getting real feisty
alright the users picked it up
they're fast okay I can mute it yeah
because that's probably just disturbing
everyone something was cooking I should
probably turn that off right yep they're
about to have dinner
yeah they were about to have dinner
let's see what else do I have here
oh you still have more I got looking way
higher than mine mine was like a 50
something I can analyze this fake blood
oh this is gross
oh so the thing is he has like he
basically has like a DNA like analysis
thing in his mouth and he just knows
every so he just analyzed he puts things
in his mouth analyze your I'm like what
you know it's a it's a it's an Android
man I didn't find this shoe that is
really disturbing oh my god there's
blood on her shoe that's frickin
horrible they were best friends a while
ago this is the scene is I'm okay 80% I
think I can I think I can
I think I can do it all right that's
real good
I want to see how you approach this I'll
tell you why and we can actually analyze
after which is a little - oh this guy
okay I located the hostage and I got
shot one thing I don't think I've ever
heard a child say I'm begging you name
Oh see you view it I didn't I had to ask
that's awkward
I know know a lot of things about you
okay so I can approach slowly oh he's
getting a little rustled as our UK Fox
he's getting wrestled we're gonna gain
his trust and do our best here mm-hmm
I'm gonna I'm gonna calm him
oh this is really interesting
um I I'll tell you later after after we
gonna do this Wow I did not have this
scenario at all I actually didn't see
this when I played it at the event so
I'm lying to him yeah what are you gonna
do I'm gonna I'm going to play the the
daughter did nothing wrong she did
nothing okay I'm gonna stop moving okay
I'm gonna talk about the yes I did that
okay we got 89% that's really good no a
lot of people died we kill the cop I'm
gonna be sympathetic yeah I like it
and so we have a what's up Keith
Richards little 420 this still makes me
so uncomfortable this you gotta accept
yeah get him out of here
we're good well yeah that's as far what
I know about hostage negotiations in
real life but yeah you gotta you know
you gotta give him discipline okay
oh I'm gonna make crusts
[Music]
I want a car when I'm outside the city
I'll let her go mmm
now let's compromise that's what I did
reassure you sure Oh
Honda Wow you talked
okay holy smokes
Kali the negotiator and it's real it's
this is real [ __ ] up actually you know
what they kill it big fun so they kill
him anyway
some that's some ish there man I'm not
happy about though so this is something
it's actually sits in edits right now
but I do have a preview coming up like a
full like opinion on this no and the
thing the thing about Connor as a
character is that he is the neutral like
he is how you calibrate your response to
these things so in context like I am
still uncomfortable with this scene
because like I used I feel like really
bad about what I did but also if you're
thinking about it from like what Connor
did like if you're role-playing Connor
it's a little bit different and so you
see that scene from Paris games week
with Kara the the one with the abusive
father that one's a little dark that
one's really dark but I played it it's a
similar issue that you're dealing with
Mike played it very differently
oh so this is really cool this is no
we're good actually this is one of my
favorite things about the game is you
get this flow chart and obviously we
have actually you could play this
earlier than though so I'll start from
the beginning we have oh wait there's
something you can do here that we missed
that we missed oh I know what it oh I
thought I did it and I guess we didn't
do it I also you do you get points for
things and I talked about that in my
interview with David cage as well that's
on the site by the way game saw calm if
you haven't checked it out you should um
there's something you can do where you
involving the cops gun that we didn't do
there's some only to use the gun on him
maybe I mean this is from the searching
for clues so there's a there's a clue we
didn't find even though we searched
really thoroughly there's the thing that
we didn't do but it leads to the same
result which is confronting between
outside negotiating could have gone
very differently obviously this branch
is a lot and then we see that you had
something yeah I can show them so like
well right you actually died yeah so
like that means you died I liked mine
because I felt a lot less worse right
because in this scenario it's like okay
we were able to talk down the rogue
Android and the thing that I was gonna
bring up that was interesting is like
you know the little discs on their their
forehead color it changes color I did
not know that until this second time
through with you is that as your
probability was going up you know I
guess yellow is more neutral and then
blue must be like oh he's like more like
okay blue is like the Android is
functioning the way it's supposed to
yellow is like yellow from what I played
it was like it's encountering some sort
of distress okay or is like processing a
situation that could be dangerous
at least from what I played and then red
is like yeah it's gone so TV show for me
it was red the whole time no matter what
I did like I was able to get the
probability to go up but it was never
like at a blue state and so mine was
like at the fifth like that maybe high
50s really it was really bad I didn't do
enough investigating and like my answers
were not necessarily pleasing to him so
yeah as you can see in my oh whoa so you
in he jumped with several doors exactly
and then I was lucky enough where
there's a button prompt and if you do it
fast enough you can save Emma by like
pulling her like back to the ledge and
then you in turn because your moment
your for momentum is going so fast you
end up falling off the building with
Daniel the demon and in that case I was
like oh okay you know what
I did my job as the negotiator I'm an
Android and I'm probably get you know
brought back to life anyways because I
did my job right whereas like in that
case I actually felt a little bit
sympathetic because I was like dude
that's kind of messed up but I guess you
could also say in some hostage
situations that would happen yeah yeah
given the fact that he's an Android you
know like this prom is probably more
likely I don't know in the future if
that was to happen that they would
probably just destroy right right well
so yeah you see that's justified
you'll see in the game that like
androids can be repaired which is one of
the things that's things that happens to
Kara
the character from the like like she's
from the original like 2012 short that
Quantic Dream did I do want to point out
really quickly that we have like the
yellow bar is a game changer which means
that when Connor left for Emma and fell
and died you like change the outcome of
your game
Oh Oh the main characters can't die like
yeah I was talking to them to cage and
like so many people they were like oh
yeah the characters can die and I was
like wait like just they can just die
and yet do you get to do do you get to
replay the scenario also in the main
game look at replay things at any time
but I was with the build I was playing I
I wanted to get everything yeah let's
play it one more time and see like if we
can figure out what other avenues there
were besides the - that sounds good
sorry do the people that if I miss chat
I'm kind of in full of Detective mouths
so like I kind of stuff mission
accomplished says Brian yep get rekt I
don't know goo he didn't deserve it well
maybe he did he did kill like he killed
a bunch of yeah I've lowered our volume
rabbits if you're saying we're kind of
loud stop abusing robots okay I'm just
not gonna even look at the gun okay and
okay let's see you like let's see what
this piece of evidence I missed was sure
being gaming says it's kind of lame to
shoot him no matter what I think that's
only if you're able to talk him down so
in my case he ended up jumping I'm
guessing there was a gun option too so
we could potentially shoot Daniel we
could I think keep Connor away which is
what happened which is what happened at
PSX if you saw that day they did end up
using the gun which I would rather not
do
I want to see what else that's fair
there was a couple more end state
options from what I could tell I think
so we're gonna go through a couple more
scenarios obviously but you should
should be coming out to the US tomorrow
if you guys want to try it again we're
playing on the Australian version
because it's out for them I was just
able to use one of our Australian
accounts game saw Australian counts I
can't talk today on a Monday
sparks ago says I thought it would
involve more gameplay this is a first
responder I don't know what I'm missing
I just did this it was his face it was
hands his bullet wound right what uh I
just didn't I did that plenty at
multiple times where I just kind of went
really fast
oh and I did reconstruct it because I'm
not paying attention because I'm
thinking about all right gonna
reconstruct this alright so we found the
gun right which was one of them I'm
gonna see if I'm true I want to see what
happens if I'm truthful with Daniel okay
okay he's making a run he's got the girl
in his hand obviously oh yeah cop shot
the deviant you get shot you shouldn't
be dead from that that looks like a
shoulder wound hostage witnessed the
shooting which is horrible they were
man's we're seeing where the gun went
which is over there okay so that's all
three can we not do that listen we did I
just I want the gun so I can see what
happens if I if I tell him the truth
that I have a gun okay
you can't hear what they're saying in
terms of Cody are you talking about the
game or us fry the game I can turn up
the game well if I don't need this part
but yeah yeah
if you haven't watched the movie the
negotiator you should I thought it was a
very good ok I've unlocked a dialogue I
meant oh he gets shown about her would
he's good he's got armor body armor okay
I'm just gonna go outside I'm just gonna
do it
apparently they showed off most of the
headings in the IDI trailer but hey you
get to go through them with us
[Music]
what about you this is so I didn't
understand what happened at all
it was 41% this is gonna go well okay
can you gain his trust
let's see release hostage yeah I was who
are you armed yes
okay so the gun if you tell the truth
you just don't have an option to shoot
him I guess all right
okay I wanna I think I had to I think I
missed it yeah that was a panic decision
[Music]
yep until we did that in my reminds me a
heavy rain same director this whole set
is making me anxious
I know
never let anyone humiliate me again ever
okay I guess this happens what are you
gonna do Oh
[Music]
let's kind of lower the percentage right
oh it didn't do anything okay
I'm so scared oh my god I don't like
this at all I don't either
just call her in it
I don't know what happens if I give him
a car let's see yeah okay oh I didn't
get shy oh I just got shot yeah that's
like the same as mine pretty much
well this let's see if how it looks in
the flowchart okay great we've scarred
for life
Jesus hey you're safe
oh so my software instability got worse
see now he's a rat oh no he's he's gone
he's on offline
I can't tell what this says then it's
okay yeah see that was what happened we
didn't do any investigating really oh so
this is a different outcome okay I have
two left I'm sure one of them is like
straight murdering I really I'm afraid
now why that was so uncomfortable oh my
god
I'm curious okay okay hold on so this is
this is one of the big so my options
were to lie I you did that yeah build I
built trust you failed to build trust so
there was one thing where you could just
like refuse what his demands yeah and
that's probably what this is but it
leads to two options and then there's
one all the way up here which is oh yeah
just knows you don't react fast enough
and she probably eats it
oh my is my god well because what else
what other outcome could there be if
right if you don't save her yeah she
probably I don't know should we try one
more time all right try one more time
your choice it I think the two options
left are she dies or he dies like what
thank you guys there are two here and
that's what I'm oh wait you cannot get
close enough huh okay alright we're
gonna try one more time and we'll see
what happens here are you gonna
investigate it all are you just gonna
leave us to get a little bit I think I
want to I want to do a middle ground
between what I say yeah that's fair yeah
one of the endings is really bad I can
guess what that one is that top left
one's got to be real dark it's the one
where I don't hit the quick time and I
fail on my job as a negotiator okay yeah
but isn't this the same than what they
had at e3 this was a PSX I don't know
this wasn't the same one because the e3
one was with the car oh right the East I
don't care the car one was at
Paris games week sorry III was the one
where it was like the dad being really
abusive to the daughters was I was
trying to save
yeah that's Cara that was that III am i
I must be mr. Behrman I don't I don't
always remember III is a hectic time I
know I I only remember that because I
was thinking oh man that's real scary
but it might have been it might have in
Paris games week I might have forgotten
there's just a lot of events obviously
gun oh no much worse as rabbits I don't
want to know that I don't want to know
what the much worse is then if if what I
said wasn't bad enough I like that
someone says were bad at engaging the
comment section as you're talking to the
comment commenters what happens if I
don't talk to the dude right now who
captain Alan yeah I think I think you're
bypassed that though oh this point
should be doing it I think right in the
bathroom oh I did that too actually and
I did not get the look at option there's
nothing in there all right all right
fascinating okay this one was at PS X
okay got it the carrot so or that Cara
storyline is I did play some of it and
it Oh what you go back here I didn't go
back here Eric Smith is gonna play this
car at the car storyline is really dark
what is interesting okay fish I could
save the fish yes
oh please back into something you're
good you're good
what enough water okay I so this is
affecting my software stability as well
which is interesting
no so that's a picture yep I did that
one it just tells you who to please
don't let the kid dive clean I
absolutely am NOT gonna let the child
die oh my god it's fair
okay so we got everybody's names yes
this is the demo that they should at PSX
um is there anything else in here that I
can look at there's gunshots in the wall
see I should see I feel like I shouldn't
be taking my sweet son yeah they got
body armor Callie is this therefore the
any sword not yet Himmel it'll be out
tomorrow in the US I heard it's not even
out in the UK yet so I would just kind
of wait wait it out a little bit
can we talk about how swanky this house
is oh it's nice it's it's they've even
got their own pool from what I can tell
yeah there's a dead police officer there
now but you know they have a pool how
long is this demo a steady bong yeah you
almost got me there
Danny Vaughn it's I think it's like 15
to 30 minutes and okay so what's an arm
you'd be like 15 plus minutes but if you
did multiple scenarios like we are you
know trying out it could probably be
like an hour plus you think like have
you tried every scenario if you tried to
go through everything yeah yeah cuz I
would say it's about 15 15 plus minutes
for one scenario depending on how
involved you get maybe a little less it
just depends because as you saw Kali the
second time we went through she didn't
even do this part of the investigation
she kind of just did like one
investigation that walked out the door
and so that one went really quickly real
quick yeah i reconstruct I see I'm doing
this a lot more quickly because I've
done it like six times now but yeah
that's fine
so we're gonna go through the he was
gonna be replaced okay so one of our two
options is really dark the other one
apparently is us you know taking them
out our selves so I but there's three
other options so okay so I'm keen I'm
just gonna see I'm gonna just see if i
han't if I get more information
uh-huh but I still handles I handle the
Oh
oh that just changed how I
okay I want to analyze that Wow I want
to analyze that body outside you the
thing you can try I don't know if this
will help you mm-hmm
I don't know if it'll let you do it to
try to get an r1 r1 yeah you can change
I guess camera perspective that helps
you or not
oh wait oh so this is the this is this
yeah they picked up the news I TM TV
that's exactly what's happening okay
good I've already checked the bedroom in
previous playthroughs I'm just kind of
like going through yeah that's just for
the name but pretty much his desk
stranding a ps4 exclusive also I believe
so
who knows that's like a I guess I'll
check the bedroom cuz I do on his name
Daniel will help you Daniel nebulus
targa says this game is not for everyone
yeah I agree I think that for sure this
is one of those games that are gonna be
you know definitely more fun for some
than others obviously but you know if
you're if you're into being a detective
I'm getting those vibes right now you
know a negotiating a little bit but it's
a little stressful it's stressful when I
handle it less like I did the first day
knock him down where you did it like a
proper negotiator right well you know
why I did it the way you should do it
that was totally not stressful but child
didn't hear gunshots hey we saved the
fish aqua wolf you'll see it soon we
saved that fish yeah I wonder if that's
one of the things that like I didn't
find in the Terry Mosher or a Terran or
tar and Walker the demo is available
tomorrow for like priority like the rest
of the world we're just on that early
Australian because it's out it's like
the next day in Australia so we're able
to get the demo that one there in the
future over there
yeah I wonder can I is there anything I
can do okay I'm gonna do that did I do
him already now I'm gonna do him one
more time but I'm not gonna pick up the
gun okay no gun alright okay I got a
gunshot wound before I forget
Conroe Texas ed people liked until dawn
quite a lot it could be good yeah it's
hard to say I'm told Don's a little
different though it's all guns is not
bike yeah I know but maybe from like
like the gameplay mechanics yeah maybe I
don't know I guess it's not really that
similar but you never know
it's not it's definitely definitely not
made by the same people right i just i
think the like actual detective part of
it i just i this there's some writing
thing hiccups for me like i think
they're uh oh there's a surprise
maybe I should get the gun then
intimidate with the gun but but that you
have the gun right that's just you and
no I don't have the gun yet oh okay
there it is I wasn't sure if that was
the gun you actually picked up it is
okay that you can choose whether or not
to use LMA exs this is all I'm waiting
for it awesome
you're about one month away soon do you
have a time limit to look or can't keep
looking so for me I afk tit and it like
actually was telling me to go out really
I happen to like to leave my desk in the
game on and it was already trying to
push me out the door now I don't think
it actually made me step out but like it
was pretty much like hey you're taking
too long here you might want to go out
there we go yeah we are taking too long
yeah so this kind of happened for me I
guess you don't have I get I know I have
to it wouldn't let me oh really yeah
okay so there's a kind of time every
time she's Batman still the best
detective that's there all right I took
so this one when you took our sweet time
which might actually affect things your
name
a lot of things about you I've come out
of this
fifty percent this is where I was at
this was my life Callie okay so as we
were walking later you can l1 yeah I'm
gonna doesn't really empathize there we
go we're the same
yeah I'm not a oh wait I have to put on
I'm an idiot I shoulda lied because but
sorry everybody
alright now we'll play the other game
okay well now we'll see tonight are
those other options locked now how do I
help that man you can't what I remember
man oh oh I didn't get not get this prom
oh [ __ ] don't why me alright okay that's
fine you know what I want to see what
happens if I fix this man okay did I
help the cop i unlock something told you
alright uh possible cause what was that
one for it's just a zoom in on his face
okay what happened I'm gonna is that guy
dead
what will you choose there's no way out
Daniel Oh what you've done is too
serious the only question is whether or
not you take another innocent life I'm
gonna see what happens if I don't get
close enough to him so if I don't get
close enough and that means I can't
catch her which I'm really afraid of
actually yeah
is that in green graphics yeah I mean
pretty much because like yeah we're
playing yeah we're playing
I can leave the game audio higher two
guys want you just tell me you guys I
just I'm curious cuz it was one of the
things that was an option
yeah
Kimura Daniel killed the father the wife
got away but he's also killed some cops
now he has any Android can't wait for
this game to come out it looks awesome
I'm so scared right now I'm really
scared I think I think it went for like
92 so nice David that I would assume
maybe 12 a.m. Pacific or 9 a.m. or sorry
12 p.m. or 9 p.m. favor don't save her
no I can't let her die are you kidding
you can let her die no I'm gonna let her
die okay so I got the same outcome you
did yeah I wanted to see what would
happen if you just did my super just
wanna do that I super don't want to do
that you can check it out by yourself
later okay
alright that's fair oh I get to die
happy in stability though for the u.s.
demo will be out tomorrow
man she's never gonna trust an Android
ever again let them all thing is no she
wants Kelly's too good of a person I
listen I'm not doing that live on a live
stream sorry I you can check it out
yourself the demo is gonna be out soon
rest in peace Connor he comes back he's
an Android
alright let's let's check out the
flowchart okay okay
saving the fish is something backup we
unlocked and then we've got the same
package I did so it has nothing to do
with yeah so that's that bad option I
guess
well the gunning down is one of them
right yeah you think you can quickly do
the gun quickly shoot him yes I do that
because I will attract like a freaking
idiot this time oh no it's all right
tough decisions are being made alright
quickly do this one will satisfy part of
the chat we're not gonna do the the bad
bad one we're gonna but we are not gonna
not gonna let this negotiation go the
way this Android thinks he's gonna have
we're not gonna compromise we're not
gonna be nice we're just gonna we're
gonna get it get it done in a more
aggressive way I guess but yeah we're
definitely not doing the other one
that's scary oh there's this guy no it's
this one let's take out their gun and
intimidate and convince him because that
is a surprise apparently according to
rabbits are pretty cute rabbits are
pretty cute has that has that has the
deets so I think I do need to get his
name so I need to go to the girls
okay we'll try your way rabbit we'll see
if we can do it and if you steer us in
the bad path I'm gonna be very upset
okay we're getting his name we won't do
the bad ending Joe hey even though I was
being an internet troll and trying to
get Kelly to do it we won't do it I
promise you how did you get the demo
says dead shot we have the Australian
version which is outer aid it's only in
the australian store but you need an
australian PSN to be able to do that
which we are lucky enough to have from
our australia gamespot office so thank
you Edmund Tran actually the reason why
I have the Australian account was
because I was able to play destiny too
ahead of time it's that's I probably
should have won too
it was like a nice little head start it
was like I forgot how much time I had a
hair was okay all right here we go so we
got to get the gun though right yeah we
got to get the gun and I got to tell him
a lie which which is uh yeah he was a
first responder okay and then they also
somebody in the chat pointed out
something that pops up when you pick up
the gun so I'm gonna not zoom through
that I'm going okay look at that cuz it
may or may not be illegal for Andros to
hold guns so we're gonna find that out
in a second cool reconstruct me I'm an
expert at this now I'm so good at this
mm-hmm LM a yak says I'll lock myself in
a room and play this by myself that's
the mood to play this to get into the
game and the character's destiny to
sadface hearts broken disappointment
yeah relatable I I used to be a defender
and then now I just can't anymore
even I've fallen victim to calling it
but I will play the expansion and it'll
be a nice fun like a week or so you're
gonna buff those exotic weapons it's
like fun but anyways back to this
there's a weapon right there okay and
that's the weapon that I am going to lie
about this - yeah we're gonna lie we
don't have one
when will the demo be available in the
USS mega movies my guess is 12 a.m.
Pacific or 9 p.m. Pacific potentially
but I don't quote me on that I'll try to
find out for you though let me see if I
can ask our news team if they can help
me out with the actual time okay
androids are strictly forbidden to carry
or use any type of weapon taking it okay
so I think it might have been rabbits
are pretty cute who said that in the
chat so thank you oh I can look at this
oh okay so I thought that was an
automatic thing I actually was doing
that just by doing yeah yeah from turns
out alright I'm gonna go in there we go
time - why
I'm gonna get shot doesn't faze me cuz
I'm Connor but I'm getting read uh uh
back to boys
[Music]
sorry I'm totally like asking for a date
here
that's so dark nebulous but you do you
good what's up Jay Shah 71 all right
okay I'm gonna reassure him I'm not
gonna hurt you except officer needs
first aid how do you know good thing the
winds not blowing my right side of my
coat
I know Connor wants me John will clean
yeah it's very different this
conversation is very different based off
of like you knowing thank you blaming it
there we go
[Music]
don't we all Daniel
which one we go why would you lie
we'll never let anyone humiliate me
again never
anymore nebula Stargate can you spot
this in 2.5 scores so it's not gonna be
a 7.5 I've done coop bosses and Connor's
Loki John wick
how could a last chance I don't know
Falacci gun I don't remember what we did
to get I think use gun is next
that's impossible Daniel let the girl go
and I promise you won't be hurt
don't want to die
human lives I think I need to upset him
more in order together gun oh geez
smooth bout ones the line man okay I
think this is the point where we know
there's the same thing now savor savor
savor jolly
we can't how do you how do you get the
gun to go out once I get close enough
I don't closer clearly there's no I do
not want to choke a that's fine clearly
there's lots of stuff going on right
it's fine oh you know what we saved the
hostage and everything we did it again
it turns out you can get the same ending
for multiple yeah just so you guys know
12:00 a.m. Eastern it's 12:01 Eastern
tonight or tomorrow morning I guess you
could look at it that way so which is
like 901 Pacific yes yes so there you go
I'll let this play out and then we'll
wrap it up and then it's like yeah well
he did what I wanted this is what a
captain Alan says
I'm so frustrated yeah it's fine
it is what it is sometimes you can't you
can't predict every part of the
flowchart yeah that's so so I mean I
guess like it is interesting that you
can get like there's multiple ways
multiple ways to get well obviously you
can visually see it there most boys to
get there but yeah yeah
Oh beans uh anyways thoughts other than
go read your article obviously which has
a little bit more gameplay and thoughts
there
of course yeah I have stuff that you can
read in an interview with David cage
himself awesome thanks for playing of
course yeah so tomorrow or tonight you
can try this out yourself 9:00 p.m.
I don't want Pacific appreciate you guys
all tuning in Calla we've back tomorrow
gets about daily at 11 to 11:30 with
Michael giving you six new stories in
less than 30 minutes or hope just the
top story top story o top stories I've
been saying it wrong I'm glad you're
here to correct me the top stories in 30
minutes or less and I'll probably be
back tomorrow at 11:30 with another fun
stream so come back hang out with us and
we appreciate you guys all tuning in
thank I so much and who so have you do
say